hey guys today is a really exciting day
I feel like I say that every time I
start a vlog we're on our way to go
Pokemon hunting to a secret spawn trap
that Matt found online
the dog is clearly excited about it so
is Jenna oh yeah
Jenna's driving us today on this
adventure so that that can Pokemon hunt
Matt the human not the dog although if
the dog a Pokemon hon I'm pretty sure
you were too he does have his own iPads
let's go pick up Matt human whoa why not
I get my pokemon up slings are happening
I really thought I'd be over this game
by now but I'm not
honey it's okay we're gonna go and then
you're gonna go for a little potty
number nickel for a ride okay my Pokemon
won't load Oh service we're done
they're still down on me um Matt hello
welcome to the car thank you where are
we going we're going to Baldwin Hills
mark I think it's called okay it's in
Culver City and it's supposed to be a
known location where you can find a site
there so we're trying to have a little
variety in our pocket X's and so
hopefully we can find the site there and
have a successful trip traveling around
guys pokemons not working how ESA's of
the Pokemon hunting if the servers are
down this is ruining everything
yeah compose a serious problem and
that's specifically what you guys pick
me up for exactly this isn't good
hopefully in the commute to our secret
location there will be some fixes and we
can log on to the game we just told them
where we're going well yeah I know but
it's still like a it sounds cooler but
we are here for the cypher it's been
spotted it's just not decreasing in the
car to catch it we're ready to find
cypher I keep calling the Sith Lord and
that doesn't think it's funny it's like
about three steps away it's saying so it
should be here somewhere quite good
having no luck over here the server just
keep going down my game he's crashing
really is not fun at all I mean the game
is fun god this game sucks man no we
freaking crashed
I dropped a lure over there though but
nothing cuz it crashed
you got him know about didn't you I did
not a high level out but still got him
today was a really awful day the servers
have been down the entire day I got zero
Pokemon 0 at least nothing that managed
to get one of the Sith Lords not
actually named but that's what I'm
calling it I've got Pokemon in my pocket
because I'm trying to crack some eggs
hatch some eggs
so making gems breakfast she has to go
to a meeting while making her some
breakfast the dog is eating his
breakfast today's a cleaning day also a
two more videos day yesterday was
so upsetting
we went out full intention of Pokemon
hunting and guess what we got nothing
what for good measure
Maddie's also getting a haircut today
actually not a haircut he's just getting
a bath we took him to the dog park
yesterday he had the best time ever but
he got real real dirty little bit of
milk um some feta cheese now we just mix
these up
for just about me with salt magical
don't wash eggy everywhere
we are thank you breakfast is served
thank you you ready to go we gotta go
get your haircuts you're gonna look
really handsome wait wait let it bow and
we're not going this way
let's go somebody's really excited about
the haircut back there obviously quite
pumped up about it you're not really
actually getting a haircut he's just
been he gets so dirty he's a white dog I
try to give him a bath myself and he
literally will run around my entire
house and just destroy everything so
he's gonna look all fresh and clean
aren't you baby
man's getting his hair cut I got myself
Starbucks I have about the chain minutes
before he's done and there is a gym up
here and I'm gonna try to take it it
looks like these dips that happens
sniffle set up for people who are
playing Pokemon it's so hot up like 90
degrees
can't see on my screen but I managed to
win one round and I win two rounds and
in particular the gym but the problem is
Maddie is done with his haircut now so I
gotta go pick them up I don't think I
have time to do this one more time
we'll take it over this gym Maddie I'm
illegally parked
I'm not illegally illegally parked but
like I mean you know it says no parking
Tuesday it's Thursday so we're okay
reviving my Pokemon and then we're gonna
play but I need some of your
conditioning back on I'm sorry
holy moly is it hot
huh tell you well the Gemini overtook
today Jannah in the car and it was so
hot out they probably know you've been
outside no I've been inside she's been
inside it's hot out I definitely almost
had a heat stroke and I took over this
gym it took me about 40 minutes and then
just some about to drop my Pokemon in
for the Big Takeover somebody else
plops theirs and takes ownership of it
edible no shut up it was so upset I do
not get him too much of a trend it
didn't cut any of it I know any of it
all looks good a little round design
looks good well I mean we have a poodle
dog so if that's what they look like
did you see my custom Xbox controller I
made yeah I don't think I did actually
oh I'm not sure
wait I send it to a bunch of people's I
thought you might have seen it
let me show let me show you yeah no but
look at mine is it mine I might be full
screen are you ready
here's mine do you have the other pick
and here's Jenna's oh I didn't save the
other pair girl oh look at that looks
good yours mine they basically are very
similar I like mine I like yours too but
I like yours too
I lost my drink the un-lemon yes so like
lemon worried think I'm a mutant Oh
Maddie that's why I'm here uh somebody
here Oh
guys someone that was at the door
earlier much much earlier cuz we just
went and took over a couple of gems
outside delivered me something then I'll
be unboxing on tech Tuesday I can't wait
I'm so excited I want to open it right
now but I I want to say that for Tuesday
I'll see you later I don't even know
what this vlog all even was so um I'm an
edited now I'll see you guys later
nyeeehhh Oreo stopped chocolate chip
cookies I mean that's basically what
dreams are made of